bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde je suis ravi de vous retrouver
au sommaire ce soir un insoumis à la
présidence de la commission des finances
il s'appelle eric coquerel il a 63 ans
et il va piloter l'une des commissions
les plus stratégiques à l'assemblée le
règlement voulait qu'elle revienne à
l'opposition c'est chose faite mais
qu'est nos positions offensives
constructive ou stériles beaucoup de
députés redoutent déjà cette présidence
grand décrypte haletant un enfant avec
nos invités sur ce plateau à part mais
aussi ce soir d'un documentaire
exceptionnel qui sera diffusé après
c'était émission sur notre antenne 4
reporter de la rédaction d'accepter ont
suivi pendant des semaines la campagne
de plusieurs candidats aux législatives
nous les recevrons récit à partir du
terrain d'une élection bloc contre bloc
qui a déjoué tous les pronostics et puis
tous ces sujets on va les aborder avec
notre grand témoin ce soir c'est l'une
des figures de la nu peint 6,6 au palais
bourbon et défend depuis toujours la
cause des femmes et elle se lance dans
son premier roman publié chez grasset
assemblée et es histoire d'amour
croisées dans les coulisses du pouvoir
le tout sur fond de harcèlement par un
député toute ressemblance avec la
réalité bien sûr fortuite clémentine
autain est avec nous ce soir voilà pour
le menu c'est parti on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs rarement l'élection
d'une présidence de commission n'aura
suscité autant de passion c'est donc
l'insoumis eric coquerel qui pilotera la
puissante commission des finances au
grand dam du rassemblement national la
guerre est-elle déclarée d'ailleurs où
on se posera la question entre ces deux
parties bonsoir clémentine autain
bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce plateau
député la france insoumise de
seine-saint-denis romancière puisque
vous signez votre premier roman chez
grasset assemblée on va en parler dans
la deuxième partie bonsoir jean noël
barrot merci d'être là député modem des
yvelines membre de la commission des
finances je précise donc que vous n'avez
pas pris part au vote ce matin on est
revient draps le rassemblement national
également présent dans ce débat mais à
distance depuis la très belle ville de
pauillac bonsoir monsieur le député
grégoire de furnaces merci d'être avec
nous députés au rassemblement national
de gironde et puis bon soir benjamin
morel on a besoin de votre expertise
comme souvent sur ce plateau
constitutionnaliste et professeur de
droit de droit public alors d'abord les
faits rien que les faits j'ai envie de
dire le récit homérique de cette
élection à la commission des finances
vous y allez homérique elle était l'amie
blakowski si j'ai bien compris pour
démarrer
[Musique]
dansaert stéphane bon sens mais rien de
bonsoir à tous si j'ai bien compris ce
soir peut-être pas homérique céphale
iliad non plus la vie parlementaire mais
c'est à peu près aussi palpitant qu'une
série netflix aujourd'hui
pour l'épisode du jour dans la
collection de la la présidence de la
commission des finances le ce matin le
l'élection d'eric coquerel paraissait à
peu près sûrs et mais il ya eu du
suspense jusqu'au bout c'est à dire que
le premier tour et bien eric coquerel
arrivée en tête mais eu suspension avant
le troisième tour négociations en
coulisses entre le r ndlr et puis quai
charles de courson qui représentait le
groupe utile et donc inquiétude celle du
ps regardez olivier faure qui publié un
tweet à cette occasion dix ans vous la
voyez l'avenir larnack charles de
courson risque d'être désigné à la place
d'eric coquerel riz bon finalement ben
finalement il a dû retirer son twitter
68 et son inquiétude qui a parlé mais en
réalité charles de courson n'avait
aucune intention de s'allier avec le rnd
erik cole très bien sûr qui a été lu un
peu comme prévu mais comme une petite
surprise eric coquerel c'est quelqu'un
qui est très présent à l'assemblée des
députés qui s'engagent le plus qui est
très un prodige ans avec le camp
présidentiel
et puis ce matin je ne sais pas pourquoi
un moment de douceur il a remercié la
majorité incroyable je dois dire que je
suis satisfait que cette élection est
respectée
j'allais dire les formes démocratiques
du fait que la majorité n'a pas pris
part au vote comme elle s'y est engagée
c'est donc quelque part
un mieux par rapport à ce que ce à quoi
on a pu assister hier ce dont ils
avaient assisté hier c'était l'élection
des deux vice-présidents et rennes a
largement parlé hier elle avait donc
évidemment ça avait indigné
les insoumises aujourd'hui - apparemment
c'est un peu mis de côté puis finlande
bien aller en plus avec la majorité
parce que pareille jean rené cazeneuve
lui il a été élu rapporteur puis alors
il n'a vraiment pas un mot de travers à
dire sur et coquerel on écoute eric
coquerel a été
élu au troisième tour mas il a eu des
propos très rassurants et moi je lui
fais confiance
on a l'impression qu'ils vont s'entendre
en fait du coup ce sont les républicains
et le rassemblement national qui
s'indignent bord se scandalise mais oui
c'est ça les séries maîtrise ya toujours
des retournements de situation ceux qui
s'indignaient un jour ne sont pas ceux
qui s'indignent le lendemain donc tout à
l'heure c'était les élèves qui étaient
indignés à l'idée que eric coquerel a
été lu et grâce à qui ou plutôt à cause
de qui écoute et véronique nouvelle ag
qui a été battu ce matin
d'ailleurs monsieur coquerel vous pouvez
remarquer la remerciera il a remercié la
première chose qu'il a fait c'est qu'il
a remercié la majorité de ne pas avoir
participé au vote mais ceux qui sont
plus énervés c'est bien sûr les gens du
r'n en l'occurrence jean philippe tanguy
qui lui étaient candidats aussi pour
cette présidence et qui estimait que
étant le premier groupe d'opposition le
poste lui revenait quasiment
automatiquement donc il parle de triche
y parle de piraterie bref il s'énerve un
peu anciennes claira tri mais ce n'est
pas dit que le vote n'était pas
démocratique j'ai dit qu'ils avaient
triché dans la présentation de leurs
candidats et dans le refus de voir que
nous étions principal groupe
d'opposition est ce que tu peux garantir
devant les électeurs qui seront unis
pendant quatre ans sur une seule même
ligne politique non voilà donc tout ça
c'est des magouilles d'appareils il n'a
pas fallu dix jours pour que le régime
des partis remplace le parlementarisme
ce domaine alors qu'est-ce que ça va
changer un président a soumis à la tête
des finances à la cuisse pence mais il a
quand même un petit peu avancer le
programme ce matin eric coquerel en
disant que c'est un post très politique
ce poste et qui ne mettraient pas saisie
des deux côtés donc il a donné deux axes
ont fait un mois que j'ai retenu c'est
d'abord qu'il avait bien décidé à
prendre le temps nécessaire pour mener
les débats en commission ce qui n'avait
pas été le cas selon lui jusqu'à présent
jusqu à quel moment prendre le temps
nécessaire ça devient ralentir le
gouvernement jusqu'à bloquer est une
question et puis l'autre inquiétude
c'était mais attention eric coquerel
s'il lé président pourra lever le secret
fiscal et risquent de se servir de ce
pouvoir est-ce qu'il va le faire
eh bien oui il va le faire il va s'en
servir
chivu pu me servir de lever des secrets
qui secoue on peut travailler avec la
commission sur les questions d'évasion
fiscale aux plateformes
j'allais dire que c'est un
quelque chose de très politique et qu'il
a aucun rapport avec des vents débat
politique personnelle bon alors je sais
que vous êtes pressé débattre juste un
petit détail qui nous a tous surpris
nous qui travaillons l'assemblée ce
matin eric coquerel avait la cravate ils
travaillent oui je sais ça paraît un
détail mais ça va tellement étonné tout
le monde qu'on lui a posé la question
bonjour prison qu'un moment donné
j'essaye de
essaye de respecter
voilà la première banque suisse par
contre y'a pas une chose je sais tout à
l'égout travail
si vous l'avez ça m'a été fait par la
personne qui l'a vendue il ya plusieurs
semaines
balayant smoke and marine le pen qui
avait demandé la cravate à tous les
députés bain pour faire un peu
respectables peut-être qu eric coquerel
vis à vis décidé qu'avec ce nouveau rôle
de président il devrait pas changer un
peu d'attitude être moins c'est ce qu'on
va voir voilà pour ce tour d'horizon
complet merci pour votre regard stéphane
clémentine autain hier les insoumis
crier au scandale on a tout entendu
qu'ils avaient des deals des accords
absolument scandaleux insupportable une
digue qui avait sauté ce soir les
insoumis ont un poste clé vous êtes
rassurés oui enfin en tout cas je suis
très satisfaite que la logique politique
les emporter c'est à dire que
renaissance les députés de la majorité
n'ait pas participé à ce vote
conformément à l'idée que la présidence
de la commission des finances revient à
l'opposition et que la nuque c'est à
dire la force la plus importante
numériquement dans l'hémicycle nous
sommes 151 et bien lui reviennent ce
poste stratégique de présidence de la
commission des finances avec mon ami
notre camarade eric coquerel donc c'est
vraiment une belle nouvelle pour nous ça
n'enlève rien à ce que nous avons dit
hier puisque hier le problème c'est
c'est assez complexe simple pour
expliquer on va baver dessus voilà il ya
deux vice présidences et à la fois pour
le n est pour la nuit baisse bon oui
mais si on était sûr la logique par
points nous aurions dû avoir beaucoup
plus et notamment un questeur sur trois
est ce qui est très étrange c'est que la
majorité qui n'en est plus une mais qui
continue de penser qu elle est
majoritaire dans cet hémicycle s'octroie
comme par le passé deux questeurs sur
trois alors si vous voulez bien on va
pas rouvrir ce débat qu'on a largement
voile a détaillé hier jean noël barrot
dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes ce
soir vous n'avez pas participé au vote
vous ne le regrettez pas donc pas du
tout il est bien naturel que les forces
d'opposition à l'assemblée nationale
occupent des postes de responsabilité au
bureau de l'assemblée nationale
et à la présidence de la commission des
finances s'agissant d'eric coquerel moi
je combats fermement ses idées je dois
bien reconnaître que dans la législature
qui vient de s'achever il a été un
membre assidu de la commission des
finances on connaît sa force de travail
même si on n'est pas d'accord avec lui
ensuite sur les craintes qui se sont
exprimés à de maintes reprises sur les
prérogatives qui sont celles du
président de la commission des finances
et du rapporteur général du budget à
titre personnel je considère qu'elles
sont nécessaires et qu'il est bien
qu'elles puissent être exercées la
mission du parlement c'est aussi de
contrôler et donc s'est mis cette
mission de contrôle doit être exercée
par les députés en général par le
président de la commission des finances
en particulier maintenant je souhaite qu
eric coquerel fasse un usage qui ne soit
pas politique d'une autre de ses
prérogatives qui est celle de l'article
40 qui permet de décider si certains
amendements sont recevables ou non alors
que vous n'êtes plus du tout sur la
crainte du secret fiscal mais au
contraire du déroulement des débats sur
les amours d'un mouvement et je souhaite
en commission et je souhaite que il
préserve le climat de sérieux de
collégialité dont il a parlé dans son
propos tout à l'heure qui règne à la
commission des finances et que nous
puissions travailler sereinement donc
tout va bien pour vous ce soir à
condition qu'il n'y ait pas de blocages
au niveau des amendements et du déroulé
des faits convives d'amin d'élections
pluralistes c'est très clair alors
grégoire de fournès j'ai l'impression
que le son que je vais être un peu
différent que danton tokpa depuis cette
élection des mots extrêmement forts
présidence aux élections illégitimes
piraterie a dit le candidat battu jean
philippe tanguy qui briguait cette
présidence la guerre est déclarée avec
les insoumis à l'assemblée
le le fond du problème en fait c'est que
madame madame autain a fait un énorme
mensonge il n'y a pas de groupe nuque à
l'assemblée nationale il ya quatre
groupes socialistes et les fit
écologistes et communistes mais il ya il
n'ya pas de reconnaissance légale de
groupes nuque qui d'ailleurs qui n'est
pas un groupe u10 qui n'est pas un
groupe déjà mais qui n'est qui n'est
même pas une formation unie moi je
rappelle camille est recommandé
vice-présidence les écologistes ont
refusé de suivre la stratégie deux des
trois autres groupes c'est pour ça que
là on se livre à quelque chose qui est
une tromperie finalement vis-à-vis de
des français c'est à dire qu'il ya des
alliances de circonstance mais qui ne
respecte pas l'esprit du règlement c'est
à dire de cette commission devait
revenir au premier groupe d'opposition
de la commission des finances qui était
évidemment leur action nationale mais la
responsabilité c'est celle aussi des
républicains qui ce qu'ils ont laissé
faire quelques pas laisser arriver à la
présidence de cette commission un un
député qui était un des plus radicale de
l'extrême gauche
voilà vous dit ça ce soir le un des plus
radicale de l'extrême gauche certains de
vos collègues vont très loin le député
reynès laurent jacot belli a même dit
que c'était le pire du pire de l'extrême
gauche à l'extrême gauche de l'extrême
gauche communautariste islamo gauchistes
anti capitaliste jetez plus c'est la
chronique d'un massacre annoncé je le
cite vous vous cautionnez ses mots mais
oui mais de toute façon ils l'assument
ce sont des gens qui vont aller
manifester avec le ccf qui vont qui
soucie qui soutiennent madame assa
traoré même la suppléante de monsieur
coquerel avait eu cette déclaration que
la france et tous les français à unique
et leur mère vous voyez vous voyez un
peu le niveau donc ils assument leur
positionnement politique ils assument
leur positionnement politique et donc
nous faisons que m'a écouté manifester
se fait effectivement que monsieur
cochrane est un militant radical un des
plus radicales de la france est soumise
etc etc dire ce qu'il en est alors
réponse clémentine autain sur la
radicalité et puis ensuite je voudrais
répondre avant d avoir déjà sur le
groupe c'est important parce qu'en
réalité c'est pas du tout ce qui se
passe à commission des finances qui se
passe c'est que vous avez un vote qui
est un vote par députés non pas par
groupe donc la force politique de lannux
ne vous en déplaise est une force qui
existe qui a été un label d'ailleurs
pour l'élection de tous les députés
qu'il soit 1 subie communistes
socialistes écologistes et donc oui à
151 nous sommes plus nombreux que vos 89
alors ça ne fait pas un groupe unique
vous avez raison mais dans le cadre du
vote
la commission des finances vous avez pu
observer qu'il y avait précisément de la
cohérence et de la cohésion et moi je
mens je mange je peux donner les longs
devoir inventer une voix pour la nubie
11 pour le rn 9 pour la candidate les
républicains voilà voilà c'est cohérent
à la politiquement nous sommes la force
la plus importante dans cette émission
le profil des locaux craignent on va
revenir on a même préparé un portrait
vous vous le connaissez des armes et aux
téléspectateurs un peu moins qu'est ce
que vous répondez les là les inquiétudes
elles sont voilà on sort le bazooka côté
côté rassemblement national mais on les
entend à mots plus feutrée dans la
majorité ou dans le camp présidentiel
également vous le savez qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ça
écoutez les insultes les caricatures
enfin voila je là on il s'agit de
désigner le président de la commission
des finances et que nous répond à
l'extrême droite islamo gauchiste
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise les bras m'en tombent c'est leur
obsession on connaît dans l'humeur leur
idée de toute façon les finances vous
intéresse peu puisque vous êtes
globalement plutôt d'accord avec les
logiques libérales de la majorité donc
même quand il s'agit désigner la
commission le président de la commission
des finances vous nous ramenez à
islamo-gauchiste donc voilà l'extrême
droite est fidèle à l'extrême droite et
à ses émanations
répondre à cette question est ce que la
france soumise et le premier groupe
d'opposition répondez à cette question
la première est le la nuque la première
force d'opposition
ne vous en déplaise lyonnais je n'existe
pas vous l'avez décrit en subit alors qu
il n'existe pas mais malheureusement
pour vous elle existe elle vient faire
la démonstration ce matin et hier aussi
de sa forte cohésion et je vous assure
vous avez pas fini d'en entendre parler
y a rien de neuf avait pas de cohésion
hier puisque madame rousseau et un autre
écologiste ont décidé de présenter une
candidature dissidente à celle que à
celle que les autres trois autres
exactions de la nuit pourquoi monsieur
non c'est intéressant et d'aller piquer
mois et des mois parce qu'on est chez
vous expliquer plus rien à vos bricolage
on est c'est un bricolage permanent en
fait c'est cette histoire vous bricoler
vous on parle de piraterie mais
aujourd'hui une pareille de braquage en
fait où vous vous êtes en train de faire
des alliances d'opportunités en fonction
des votes qui n'ont absolument aucune
cohérence politique pour à chaque fois
essayé de braquer finalement des postes
qui ne parviennent pas à l'aller la
subit ensuite j'aimerais donner la
parole à benjamin là c'est intéressant
je comprends que ce que nous sommes en
train de faire vous dérange et c'est
normal puisque nous sommes en train de
créer de constituer une force à vocation
majoritaire qui en effet dispute là la
majorité et le gouvernement voilà c'est
ça notre objectif c'est à la majorité
donc ça vous savez pas la majorité va
vous dérange vous comptiez vous comptiez
je vous ai laissé parler monsieur je
sais que vous avez du mal à laisser
balayer devant m vous êtes à distance sa
robe ce n'est pas moins - simple on va
laisser clémentine autain terminer puis
on avancera prennent rapidement saison
c'est calme voilà donc ce qui s'est
passé hier c'est qu'en effet deux
candidatures supplémentaires ont été
déposés par les écologistes et le but
était simple permettre aux députés de
renaissance de voter pour un ensemble de
postes sans voter pour vous être capable
d'exclure l'extrême droite de la
possibilité que vous soyez
vice-président et bien ça c'est un
combat que nous partageons aller que
nous partageons dans l'ensemble de
l'année ubs s'est effectivement que nous
n'acceptons pas que vous vous banalisez
que vous institutionnalisée alors que
vous avez dans vos rangs puisque vous
l'avez dit on peut aussi parler à la
indien qui nous a fait un discours
nostalgique soient labellisés par duel
fallait pas d'un débat de la gare des
crimes de l'oas d'autres qui sont
carrément pour rendre hommage aux
victimes comme à lyon de la dîme de
l'avortement on avait vraiment marié
sissi conserver les jours précédents va
être projeté s'il vous plaît si on se
parle on se parle des choses concrètes
dont alors benjamin vrai combat qu'être
est intéressant c'est qu'on voit qui va
qui a un front uni un trait de un front
qui est en train de se mettre en place
avec d'un côté le rassemblement national
de l'autre côté les insoumis de trois
bloqués et est là aujourd'hui le
constitutionnaliste que vous êtes il est
démocratique ce vote la démocratie l'a
emporté en réalité depuis deux jours ce
que tu as et non pour nous qui voyons
c'est un peu de l'extérieur en tant
qu'ancien analyse c'est que les choses
se sont passées entre guillemets comme
normalement elle aurait dû se passer la
désignation du bureau on va pas revenir
sur le système de points mais grosso
modo à donner des résultats qui était
attendu à l'emploi pour chipoter
acceptera la récente alors ensuite vous
pouvez considérer que certaines
formations de politique ne devrait pas
figurer au bureau mais dans le règlement
pendant le règlement par le règlement de
l'assemblée nationale il est inscrit que
et bien le bureau présentent pas assez
fort c'est de représenter ce faisant les
drames 5,5 points acceptera tout ça a
été relativement bien répartir même si
on peut discuter ensuite à la marche
pour ce qui est de la commission des
finances idem là aussi cette histoire de
premier groupe d'opposition j'ai pas
pourquoi elle a émergé depuis quelques
semaines mais elle apparaît en réalité
nulle part c'est à dire que c'est une
sorte d' idée en l'air qui tout d'un
coup est apparue l'idée d'avoir un
premier groupe la première intergroupe
d'opposition n'a rien à voir avec la
désignation du président de la
commission des finances jadis on avait
un premier groupe d'opposition qui avait
la commission des finances tout bêtement
parce que eh bien ils étaient
majoritaires dans l'opposition et goût
donc par définition d'un pendule aux
règlements ainsi que le kop exactement
de député aujourd'hui on a une vie
politique beaucoup plus éclaté donc on a
eu ces deux tours 3 tours et donc ce
faisant vous avez eu une alliance entre
groupes politiques qui par définition
mécaniquement à donner un président de
la commission des finances là dessus
entre guillemets les scrutin d'hier
comme d'aujourd'hui d'un point de vue
extérieur sont sans surprise les gens
n'avaient pas vraiment et c'est mon
point de vue aussi et je trouve assez
regrettable elle le fait d'entendre à la
fois la nuque ps et le front national où
le rassemblement national
se se fâcher alors que les
responsabilités sont partagées c'est pas
vous de choisir qui a le droit d'être
dans telle ou telle responsabilité ou
dans tel ou tel siège à l'assemblée
c'est les français qui ont décidé de la
majorité si on peut dire relative et des
oppositions maintenant le respect des
groupes et d'ailleurs c'est jean luc
mélenchon qu'il a dit lemieux en 2017
lorsqu'un poste de questeur avaient été
subtilisés si on peut dire par la
majorité à l'opposition et que quatre
airs pendant 24 heures les les
les échanges ont été paralysés ça c'est
beaucoup moins bien passées à la fois
que ça ne se l'est pas c'est cette fois
ci les présidents de groupes dans
l'hémicycle ont essayé de trouver une
solution au problème comment est-ce
qu'on alors qu'il y avait une sorte d'
usage qui faisait que ben comment est-ce
qu'on résout le problème et jean luc
mélenchon a dit une phrase très
importante et qui personnellement m'a
marqué il ya dans notre assemblée des
usages qui protègent les droits des
oppositions et les droits de la majorité
chacun doit pouvoir s'y retrouver et
donc ses usagers doivent être respectées
morales devrait voulait savoir si les
républicains
avaient voté est reine politiquement il
n'aurait pas suffi c'est à dire qu'il y
avait malgré tout le joli chaque fois le
nom du nouveau groupe liberté le
territoire on l'appellerait haute main
voilà donc il il aurait fallu que les
deux députés de ce groupe votent
également pour
qui là aussi une forme de stratégie de
respectabilité que joue le rassemblement
national depuis son arrivée en force à
l'assemblée qui n'a pas marché et là
l'idée d'une opposition constructive
respecter le parlement oui et non c'est
à dire que enfin il ya en effet une
stratégie qu'on va pas détaillé de
respectabilité du rassemblement national
qui est malgré tout relativement bien
fonctionné preuve en est le à une
position du bureau mais là le
rassemblement national était minoritaire
c'est à dire que il avait certes le
groupe le plus important mais il n'avait
pas les moyens d'étendre plus sa
majorité donc le jeu politique là-dessus
l'arithmétique était contre lui et d'une
façon ou d'une autre sauf aller chercher
des députés qui a priori ne veulent pas
voter pour vous ça ne pouvait pas
fonctionner alors à quoi peut-on
s'attendre et qui est rétablissement
eric coquerel peut-on craindre une
présidence coquerel à la tête de la
commission des finances au regard à la
fois de son parcours et puis de ses
différents engagements passés portrait
signé clément merck
il s'est fait beau pour l'occasion mais
des cravates eric coquerel n'a pas
apporté beaucoup dans sa vie dans sa
jeunesse il était plutôt blouson de cuir
et foulard noir tendance anar à
l'adolescence puis trotskiste dans ses
années étudiantes vous avez mené des
actions illégales des actions violentes
illégal peut-être un peu de temps en
temps aux marges violente en fait en
réalité j'ai jamais été un violent
j'aime pas la violence c'est pas l'homme
il prend la mer les années passent eric
coquerel troc ses santiags et son cuir
contre un vieux ciré jaune le voilà
chargé de la communication des plus
grandes courses à la voile vendée globe
whitbread route du rhum qu'il devient
ensuite l'homme de confiance d'isabelle
autissier dont ils organisent le
sauvetage en mer en 1999 nous avons une
bonne information vous confirmer et
c'est dans la bouche d'eric coquerel
responsable du pc course d abel
autissier oui donc on a eu pierre
lannier qui nous a dit que giovanni
avait vu le bateau et qu'il allait
embarquer isabelle autissier 2001 michel
desjoyeaux remporte son premier vendée
globe à peine arrivé ses premiers mots
sont pour eric coquerel j'ai quelqu'un
de formidable qui s'occupe de tout ça
pour moi et qui m'a énormément soutenu
pendant ces 93 jours ainsi que ma femme
est sans eux je ne serais pas ce soir
ici avec ce résultat là mais la
politique reprend le dessus eric
coquerel quitte les trotskistes pour
rejoindre les chevénementistes un grand
écart idéologique qu'il assume
aujourd'hui
chevènement à l'époque nous considérions
que ça pouvait être l'homme de la
rupture à gauche le candidat antisystème
que vous avez trouvé plus tard en
directement le problème c'est que je me
suis retrouvé qu'à jean pierre
chevènement surtout qui à ce moment-là y
avait bifurqué sur le au delà de la
gauche et la droite et si la question la
souveraineté était toujours chevillé au
corps la question sociale je trouvais
que c'était en nette régression c'est
pour ça que je pas resté longtemps vient
la rencontre avec jean luc mélenchon une
relation de confiance se noue entre les
deux hommes depuis 2010 est en
commission des finances eric coquerel a
su parfois nouer des alliances de
circonstance comme ici avec l'élu modem
jean paul mattei quand tu veux qu'on
fasse on fait bien trop globale chacun
quelques minutes et oui on alterne de
quoi surprendre le président de séance
nous en revenons aux amendements à
l'article monsieur coquerelles et
monsieur mattei bien voilà que ce soit
dans la voile ou un politique eric
coquerel est toujours resté dans l'ombre
d'un capitaine j'ai pas le réflexe de
penser tout de suite que ça peut être
forcément moi si je pense que quelqu'un
est mieux placé je vais je vais pour le
bien de l'intérêt collectif le l'appuyer
cette fois c'est bien lui qui prend la
barre de cette commission des finances
sous le regard inquiet de la majorité
alors jean noël barrot quand vous voyez
cet itinéraire et je remercie clément
méric pour pour tout ce travail des
archives photos à l'appui de la voile au
trotskysme en passant par chevènement
mélenchon bien sûr l'assemblée nationale
parfois avec des attelages un peu
différent que ce qu'on imagine vous êtes
adversaires ça ne fait pas un doute mais
est ce que ça vous inspire confiance
je moi je respecte l'homme je respecte
le collègue et le parlementaire
c'est cet heureux d'ailleurs que le
reportage et fait un petit focus sur le
travail qu'il a mené avec jean paul
mattei président du groupe démocrate
modem et et apparentés sur le sujet un
peu précurseur de l'impôt minimum sur
les sociétés simon si ma mémoire est
bonne qui montre que sur certains sujets
les les regards peuvent peuvent
converger où se croisent et à minima
ensuite non je crois que l'on en a une
on a une institution l'assemblée
nationale qui en a connu d'autres qui a
connu des assemblées pluraliste qui a su
y compris dans des dents des
représentations plus proportionnelle
faire aboutir des grandes avancées donc
j'ai toute confiance même si ce sera un
changement d'habitude à la fois pour la
majorité pour les oppositions et tout
change à l'assemblée nationale benjamin
morel faut expliquer peut-être sais
c'est pas une présidence pour pour cinq
ans c'est une présidence pour un an sa
hausse et on a entendu beaucoup députés
qui dit pour voir et même des
républicains qui disent on verra là dans
un an oui évidemment c'est à dire que si
vraiment eric coquerel devait ne pas
faire le job est belle pour le prochain
renouvellement serait plus en plus
difficile pour lui mais il n'y a pas de
désir lui pour faire le deuil a pas de
raison et palettes succès - terminée
madame au taquet n'y a pas de raison a
priori qu'ils ne le fassent pas par
ailleurs on a la foi en surestimer on
met interprète un peu ce rôle de
président de la commission des finances
après des passes et sera lésé cas ça
c'est un rôle stratégique évidemment ça
vous permet de a déjà dit enquêter sur
pièces et sur place acceptera mais vous
n'avez pas le droit de dévoiler ce que
vous découvrez c'est à dire voilà donc
sinon il n'y a pas droit de dévoiler
mais cette classe avec charles de
courson hier qui nous expliquait qu' un
certain jérôme cahuzac en son temps
s'était pas privé on sait qu'à utiliser
secret fiscal voit lui-même donc a
priori voilà après si jamais il ya des
choses en effet qui devait paraître
entre guillemets on saurait où regarder
et c'est donc réfléchi voilà on peut
penser quand même que eric coquerel à la
fois par je dirais esprit d'institutions
et
esprit de l'intérêt général et de
l'autre côté parce qu'en effet c'est pas
non plus son intérêt individuel et bien
ne se lancera pas dans ce type de choses
ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure le vrai
risque en réalité si vraiment on avait
une présidence bloquante ce serait
pouvoir faire plus d'obstruction à
travers un usage très je dirais très
parce parcimonieux de l'article 40 alors
qu'il s'appliquerait à travers également
une présidence de la commission des
finances qui aurait un but dilatoire
geste pourrait tomber que sur quelques
textes et par ailleurs il n'est pas
certain que pour le bon équilibre de la
commission des finances ce soit un jeu
auquel pourrait s'adonner ou voudrez se
donne eric coquerel lundi matin on a vu
les insoumis dans la précédente
législature faire de l'obstruction et
l'assumé complètement vous étiez 17 vous
relayez plusieurs heures parfois la nuit
en disant on tiendra c'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour le condom vous conseillez ça
à la commission des finances où vous
pouvez nous dire on ne va pas jouer la
montre en commission des finances gj
confiance dans eric coquerel pour
réfléchir à chaque étape à la meilleure
stratégie voilà et d'ailleurs il le fera
pas tout seul il le fera en concertation
avec l'ensemble dès élus de la nuque
baisse on va on va réfléchir mais
comptez sur nous pour à la fois enfin
remplir la mission qui est celle donnée
à eric coquerel sert de présider cette
commission donc avec deux règles
évidentes et d'utiliser bien sûr cette
position pour mener des batailles
politiques ça c'est l'évidence je veux
dire on est un c'est parfaitement
logique qu'ils utilisent dans ce sens là
ouais on a beaucoup cité valérie rabault
qui était aussi candidate qui a même
proposé pour le parti socialiste une
présidence tournante on sentait bien que
le camp présidentiel était bien plus
favorables à cette hypothèse c'est ça
très sympathique je trouve pour ma nana
compétences est un contexte et elle est
plus plus accès en tout cas en matière
de finances publiques elle a fait ses
preuves et tout le monde trouvait
compétentes quel que soit le bord
politique mais ça n'est pas au fond un
peu hostile que de lui avoir fermé la
porte non je suis pas d'accord avec ça
d'abord c'est un poste politique nous
sommes des élus ne s'agit pas de
désigner le grand administrateur de la
commission des finances qui va connaître
toute la technicité c'est un poste qui
est forcément politique c'est un député
donc eric coquerel à la légitimité
ensuite il y avait cette idée de brevet
de respectabilité
voilà et la renaissance à une logique
qui va sans doute perdurer que je peux
comprendre d'un point de vue tactique et
d'essayer de briser la nuque ce et à
chaque fois de donner des brevet de
respectabilité à certains et d'expliquer
que les autres sont de fieffés excité
ultras radicaux bon pour l'instant ça
marche pas et je j'espère bien que ça ne
va pas fonctionner et le fait que
valérie rabault avec le parti socialiste
est finalement compris à la fois la
manoeuvre des macros nice dans cette
histoire là et aussi jouer la solidarité
en faisant en sorte que eric coquerel
soit notre candidat commun pour une
raison simple c'est que il se trouve
qu'en dans les équilibres politiques à
l'intérieur de lannux nous sommes 75 les
autres groupes sont entre 20 et 30 et
donc ce groupe qui est le plus fort en
ayant aussi du score de jean luc
mélenchon à la présidentielle est bien
représentent l'ensemble sur ce post raté
alors vous aurez le mot de la fin j'en
albarel vous attendez que la mipps ex
l'eau ne lève rien aux qualités de
valérie rabault et à sa précision je me
le dire l'éducation est ce que vous
allez jouer au fond la fracture de les
jeux il faut il faut c'est pas un peu
les choses ce eric coquerel reste un
député de la nuque baisse il a le droit
de faire de la politique évidemment mais
avec la fonction avec le pouvoir vient
la responsabilité et ça je crois que nos
amis de camara nos collègues de
l'opposition sont en train de s'en
apercevoir mais on peut pas venir et
faire comme si quand on est élu
président de la commission des finances
ça ne vient pas avec une forme de
responsabilité celle de faire avancer
les travaux de l'assemblée dans laquelle
la nuque n'a pas la majorité est celle
de faire en sorte qu'il puisse y avoir
personne ne travaillerai pas remarqué
travail est une drôle d'aller jusqu'à
just avec vous non plus vous n'avez pas
la majorité l'a su eric coquerel a été
très majoritaire aulas et lucas la
bonhomie bref vous aurez le modèle quand
il dit qu'il représente toute la
commission des finances est en effet
c'est quand même un poste institutionnel
c'est à dire que vous avez un rôle qui
est un rôle de coordination des
différents rapporteurs qui est celui du
rapporteur général et de l'autre côté le
président de la commission incarne
l'unité de la commission et doit en
effet en président et en assurer la
bonne tenue des travaux la balle est
dans le camp d'eric coquerel à lui de
montrer de quoi il est capable pour
président et l'ensemble des commissaires
dont vous faites partie jean noël barrot
merci infiniment benjamin moral merci
monsieur le député grégoire de furnaces
depuis pauliac vous rester avec moi que
les motifs de temps parce qu'on va
parler à présent de votre livre tout
autre sujet assemblée et es c'est un
roman c'est de votre premier roman chez
grasset et il dresse le portrait de
trois femmes que tout oppose un homme de
pouvoir au milieu
révélateur à la fois des désirs féminins
et parfois de leurs contradictions aussi
le cadre le palais bourbon qui n'est pas
loin le mythe ou en politique non plus
alors quand une année aux féministes se
lance dans un roman très politique on a
forcément plein de questions à lui poser
comme les skis ce sujet signer marko
pogné
si on vous invite clémentine autain
c'est pour parler de votre combat pour
la cause des femmes radicales diront
certains qui fait écho à votre dernier
livre assemblée ce soir nous recevons la
romancière politique au nez aux
féministes se dire féministe aujourd'hui
est devenu presque consensuel alors que
moi j'avais accroché j'ai commencé au
niveau 80 c'est limite c'était pas le
mot lui-même est extrêmement dérangeant
gabon on est féministe et c'est bizarre
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
clémentine autain vous venez tout juste
d'être réélu député de seine-saint-denis
avec un score stratosphérique 100 % des
suffrages rien que ça bon en même temps
vous n'aviez plus de rival au second
tour
conseillère régionale d'île de france
vous êtes aussi une militante féministe
de la première heure à l'origine de
votre combat l'héritage de votre mère
mais aussi et surtout le viol que vous
subissez à l'âge de 24 ans sous la
menace d'une arme n'était pas
spécialement féministes avant même je me
disais je ne suis pas féministe je suis
féminine comme beaucoup de femmes de ma
génération autour de 15-20 20 ans et je
ne voyais pas au démarrage le rapport
entre ce que j'avais subi et le
féministe l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes c'est à partir de là que mon
engagement
viscéral et efforts dans votre dernier
livre vous parlez de la domination
masculine
l'histoire de trois femmes libres
entreprenante lille à estelle et jeanne
sont amoureuses d'un même homme un mâle
alpha dites-vous en députés une figure
médiatique
trois femmes face à leurs contradictions
à l'heure du mouvement mis tout à
travers leurs voix vous interrogez le
pouvoir de l'homme politique sur les
femmes
lila n'en revient pas d'avoir craqué
pour un homme qui portent des cravates
et se drape dans le prêchi prêcha
dominant la voix et la maîtrise
d'antoine lui donne une puissance
érotique phénoménal alors clémentine
autain ce livre est-il un roman à clé et
à l'heure où le mythe ou politique
s'invite de nouveau à la une de
l'actualité avec damien abad ce ministre
accusé de viol
cette question diriez vous que la
culture politique française protège les
auteurs des violences sexistes et
sexuelles à vous la parole
réponse oui ils maintiennent un temps
oui oui oui globalement oui alors pour
damien abad c'est particulièrement
éclairant puisque vous avez là un
ministre avec des faits relatés qui sont
dans la presse des plaintes qui sont
déposées pour des violences graves
plusieurs témoignent avec le soudan capo
berta laquelle enquête ouverte mais
plusieurs témoignages et il ne se passe
rien alors il ya un remaniement vous le
savez les annoncer dans les jours qui
viennent pour l'instant il ne se passe
rien pour vous ce serait
incompréhensible c'est le rester au
gouvernement à ce serait insupportable
insupportable et pas simplement pour moi
je pense que ce sont à la fois les
limites des féministes qui sont très en
colère du maintien de damien abad de sa
nomination puis de son maintien mais
plus largement dans la société je crois
que la tolérance à l'égard justement de
ce genre de pratique où on couvre où on
minimise où l'on tolère finalement ça
veut dire que pour vous la présomption
d'innocence puisque c'est la ligne pour
l'instant défendue par le gouvernement
on verra ce qu'il en est avec cette
ouverture d' enquêtes et le remaniement
à venir pour avoir un président de ne
peut pas ne peut pas tenir très confiant
je l'emportent sur la présomption
d'innocence je ne veux il ne s'agit pas
de remettre en cause la présomption
d'innocence dans un cadre juridique
damien abad doit d'ailleurs pouvoir se
défendre et pour qu'ils puissent
correctement se défendre sans doute
vaut-il mieux qu'ils ne soient pas
ministre en revanche politiquement
politiquement moi je suis par un
tribunal à moi tout seul
c'est pas le sujet mais politiquement il
y à un principe de précaution et un
message envoyé symboliquement à toutes
les femmes en france ce qu'ils voient
les violences dont elles sont victimes
largement impunie si on était dans un
système où tout fonctionne et
merveilleusement on n'aurait pas avoir
ce type de pratique en disant ce n'est
plus acceptable
on verra ce que va décider le chef de
l'état et sa première ministre elisabeth
baume je voudrais vous parler aussi de
cette autre affaire dans l'actualité qui
concerne une autre ministre
crise ou l'asacar au cou la secrétaire
d'état chargée du développement
elle se voit reprocher par des patients
des gestes assimilable selon ses
patientes à des viols quand elle
exerçait son métier de gynécologues il
ya même le parquet de paris qui avait
ouvert une enquête il ya deux plaintes
pour viol une autre femme qui parle de
violence gynécologique ça n'est pas la
même chose est-ce qu'on va pas trop loin
en parlant en parlant de viol dans ce
cas précis alors moi je connais pas le
détail des faits j'ai lu comme ça mais
je veux juste rappeler ici la définition
du viol le viol c'est tout acte de
pénétration de quelque nature qu'il soit
par violence contrainte ou surprise est
un viol et toute femme qui va chez un
gynécologue non conscience faire soigner
avec la menace
violence aux surprises tout acte de
praeter pas vu menace verrons ça colle
enquêtes doivent moi je suis encore une
fois on va savoir pas vous dire
exactement ce qui s'est passé et porter
un jugement précis mais je ne crois pas
qu'on puisse banaliser la parole des
femmes qui témoignent aujourd'hui de
violences qui pourraient être
proférées par une gynécologue ya
derrière aussi la possibilité
d'association qui ont envie de mettre ce
sujet au coeur de l'actualité terrible
vers nos cibles ça c'est toujours
possible bien sûr est donc vous peut pas
je ne peux pas me prononcer j'attendais
que l'enquêté se poursuive a bien sûr
que j'attends avant de réclamer soit
moralisante sandrine au sol a fait son
départ
ça pourrait se poser j'avoue j'ai
personnellement aujourd'hui se pose et
je comprends que sandrine rousseau en
tout cas pose la question je vous le
souhaiter son départ écouter s'il ya
plusieurs témoignages qui porte enfin
kiki qui nous dise qu'il s'agit de viol
je pense qu'en tout cas il faut pas le
balayer d'un revers de la main vous êtes
plus prudente que s'entraîneront oui là
dessus on l'entend un oui mais il faut
ne pas balayer d'un revers de la main on
verra ce que ce col enquête va vous dire
déjà darmana qu'on est dans un tronc on
osait un contexte de remaniement peut
imaginer et alejo il ya des ministres
qui ont été battus aux législatives a
remplacé d'anyama bien mais cette
ouverture manquée ou lutte contre les
violences et les xeo femmes grande cause
du quinquennat du précédent et puis ça a
tellement bien marché qu'on recommence
pour le prochain quinquennat grande
cause du quinquennat et vous avez
monsieur darmanin dont l' affaire n'est
toujours pas terminée voilà il s'agit
monsieur abad dont les faits sont quand
même édifiant quand vous lisez les
témoignages ans après ce et puis à
nouveau une ministre mis en cause ça
commence à faire beaucoup pour vous il
faut une nouvelle jurisprudence en gros
une plainte vos démission quand il
s'agit de ministre c'est très délicat
est la justice est beaucoup plus lente
que la politique problème mais je vais
vous dire le problème de fond c'est que
seulement 2% des femmes qui sont
victimes de viols par exemple se voit à
afin voie à la fin leur affaire lundi
cyr aboutir une grande année classement
sans suite donc si on ne considère pas
ce problème là on comprend rien s'il
faut faire voilà et il faut dire stop à
l'impunité il faut dire stop à l'antre
soi et la protection à l'intérieur de
l'univers masculin qui est celui du
pouvoir donc c'est pour ça que le
principe de précaution il apparaît un
peu raide comme pratique je le comprend
par ailleurs il peut y avoir aussi à des
moments d injustice je peux tout à fait
l'entendre mais globalement c'est si
vous voulez le fait de masse c'est
l'impunité ce sont des femmes qui ne
parlent pas ce sont des surtout des
femmes qui quand elle parle ne sont pas
écoutés et une justice qui est à la
traîne vous avez beaucoup attaché à ces
questions va venir à votre roman dans un
instant mais quand même votre réaction
les femmes en force à l'assemblée
nationale la au perchoir yaël brawn
poulet mathilde de panneaux pour des
insomnies aurore bergé pour renaissance
on a bien travaillé vous trouvez pas je
vais en règle à cela les faits me dit
sport
il se passe quelque chose oui je pense
que je pense qu'en effet c'est une bonne
nouvelle que de voir des femmes même si
ce n'est pas mon bord politique que je
vais les combattre je pense que c'est
une bonne nouvelle de voir que le temps
des femmes se traduit enfin un peu dans
monde politique oui je le dis
sincèrement mais en même temps parce que
c'est bien et gagne ça ne fait pas un
brevet de féminisme et après ça
n'empêche en rien mes désaccords de fond
radicaux très fort avec avec ces femmes
là vous avez forcément vu cette image
une de vos collègues écologistes étaient
venus avec une iconique en hommage à une
certaine cécile duflot regarder un joli
monsieur le président à l'écouté
mesdames et messieurs les députés mais
surtout messieurs visiblement c'est la
robe que portait cécile duflot son
gouvernement hollande dans l'hémicycle
de fait si en tant que jeune plus jeune
élue écologiste c'est tout un symbole
que de s'inscrire en fac dans cette
transmission là c'est que cette robe
montrent que les violences sexistes et
sexuelles de ça
les visites ça nous amène à votre roman
ouais j'y serai genre de comportement
comme on est les jolis traits finit pas
simplement la clé finalement attend pas
très joli discours très joli hommage
j'ai beaucoup aimé ce geste mais cette
séquence avec cécile duflot lui est
sifflée ça ne pourrait plus arriver dans
l'hémicycle c'est fini c'est plus
difficile mais on a eu dans le précédent
mandat en tout cas encore quelques
scènes qui était un peu un peu sidérante
alors on en vient à sembler assemblée au
fond plus que le palais bourbon elle
semblait ce sont ces trois femmes qui le
sont assemblés et es autour d'un homme
qui n'est qu'un prétexte antoine elle
s'appelle jeanne
estelle et lila alors on va essayer sans
trop dévoiler l'intrigué mais quand même
c'est pourquoi pourquoi vous avez voulu
écrire ça trois femmes aux prises avec
des contradictions un désir pour un
homme qui n'est pas forcément celui
auquel elles s'attendent elle épouse
pour le dire vite la maîtresse
officielle et puis le coup de foudre
d'une dune d'une jeune femme pour pour
celui au fond qui incarne toutes les
valeurs qu'elle déteste oui en fait
j'avais je crois envie de raconter
quelque chose de l'ordre un peu de d'une
question obsédante pour moi depuis de
très nombreuses années sur le lien entre
le désir le pouvoir
voilà qui fait partie des questions sur
lesquelles je m'interroge ce qui est
assez banal pour une féministe et comme
je trouve qu'on est dans un moment de
tension de contradiction parce que vous
avez là trois femmes apparemment libre
c'est à dire qu'elles sont autonomes
elles sont voyez ce que je veux dire
elles ne sont pas soumises non dans leur
coin et pourtant ces femmes-là retombe
dans des schémas qui sont des schémas
classiques c'est-à-dire qu'elles elles
sont dans des relations qui sont pas
pleinement satisfaisante c'est à dire
avec un homme particulièrement
bienveillants voyez ce qui les aiment
médiane il ya des pouvoirs des nations
il ya du patriarcat c'est ce que vous
voulez dénoncer parce que tu sais pas je
suis pas non patriarcat j'utiliserai pas
du tout ce terme l'un c'est pas du
patriarcat m on est des rôles de leaders
je pense qu'en france on n'est pas dans
un système à proprement parler patriat
quoi ses mérites du patriarcale mais on
reste dans une société profondément
marquée par la domination masculine ce
qui m'intéressait c'était l'imaginaire
c'est qu'elles sont apparemment libre
mais ce qui ne va pas c'est vous pouvez
faire toutes les lois sur la parité vous
pouvez permettre aux femmes d'être
autonomes financièrement et même quand
on arrive à ça il ya un verrou qu'est
celui du désir du fantasme est en fait
de la delà de tout ce que l'histoire et
les représentations font à notre image
et vous traduisez traders anaëlle ça va
c'est trois personnes à rim tension où
il retrouvait la dimension encore se
verront pourquoi ils ne sautent pas mais
parce qu'il ya 2000 ans d'histoire et
que deux mille ans d'histoire il suffit
pas d'une loi pour en sortir et donc on
est dans ce moment de bascule où il ya
un avant et un après midi où elles ont
envie d'une autre forme de relation plus
à égalité et qu'en même temps elle
retombe dans le travers d'être fasciné
par les hommes de pouvoir parce que
c'est ce qui m'a marqué je reconnais
depuis pas mal d'années bien c'est de
voir combien les femmes et notamment des
mêmes des jeunes femmes féministes
pouvait être attiré par les hommes qui
se comporte de façon très traditionnelle
de mètres carrés pas clémentine autain
mais j'avais vécu là dedans bien sûr
bien sûr que je fais partie de
ces femmes ce que je voulais raconter
aussi c'est que nous tout même on a beau
être féministe la boîte
voyez ce que je veux dire avoir essayé
de travailler il reste quelque chose sur
lequel il faut qu'on travaille et qu'on
avance parce qu'au fond ne s'est pas
très bien comment pourrait être une
relation véritablement à égalité et en
quoi elle a changé et deuxième sujet qui
va avec c'est que qu'est ce que c'est
que ce rapport au pouvoir qui ne
seraient plus incarné de façon virile et
masculine donc ça interroge le désire
mais aussi le rapport au pouvoir en il
me semble que quelque chose se meurt
justement dans tout simple que vous
choisissez qui est un homme de pouvoir
qui embellit en vieillissant qui utilise
sa position alors il est on a
l'impression maintenant il utilise sa
position que ça séduit les femmes plutôt
s'est fait tout seul je voulais raconter
maintenant qu'il lui avait offert
instrumentalisation du tout mais vous en
faites une forme de caricature au fond
on a l'impression qu'il incarne quoi le
maquereau nisme pourquoi vous l'avez
camper de manière aussi aussi presque
voilà schématique mais je le voulais
assez banal en vérité assez banal donc
appartenant au pouvoir en place tout
simplement et banale aussi n'étant pas
une caricature de l'homme viril
insensible aux féministes et pas du tout
ça
et en même temps malgré tout assez dans
les schémas traditionnels de ce que j'ai
dit de l'homme
alphabet un peu voilà il est un peu long
et très documenté notre affaire s'est
documenté merci par énormément de
discussion que j'ai eue aussi bien avec
des femmes évidemment que je connais des
assistantes parlementaires des collègues
députés et c'est vous et c'est vrai que
à partir de tous cette masse accumulés
et mes propres ce que j'ai vu ce que
j'ai vécu eh ben ça donne quelque chose
qui est comme un tableau de l'état dans
lequel on est avec une question qu'est
comment on fait maintenant c'est à dire
qu'après mis tout on ne veut plus de ça
et comment on invente ses autres
relations dans se déprend au fond cette
part du pouvoir et comme on nous parle
est imaginaire cela va être des prix de
tous âges à 100 je les fais avec un peu
d'humour oui c'est très drôle c'est
désopilant souvent c'est chez grasset
voilà toute ressemblance comme on dit
avec certains parfois on tient député
vous vous vous retrouverez qui se cache
derrière derrière qui vous rester avec
moi ça va vous intéresser et clémentine
autain va faire un gros plan à présent
sur la doua soirée documentaire qui vous
attend sur lcp juste après cette
émission législatives chronique d'une
recomposition annoncé c'est le fruit du
travail collectif de la rédaction qui a
suivi pendant plusieurs semaines
plusieurs candidats vous allez le voir
sur le terrain la percée du fn la droite
qui sauve les meubles la macro ni à la
reconquête de ses électeurs alors avant
d'accueillir les reporters qui s'il se
fie n'ont pas regardé ensemble un
premier extrait nous sommes à grigny
dans l'essonne quand le maire communiste
de la ville chaperonne un jeune candidat
insoumis dans la cité de la grande borne
regardez ce que ça donne
on n'a pas envoyé mes enfants vers les
pays à la présidentielle mais avec ces
élections la route encore l'envoyer ou
vers les pays lui c'est le candidat pour
qu'il soit notre député soutenu par jean
luc mélenchon on a besoin d'avoir un
député qui soit avec nous qui nous
aident enfin il n'y a pas une foi qui
doit manquer si vous voulez voter pour
moi ou voter pour jean et antoine
clairement ils seront très très gros
comme ça le v ne pouvez pas le rater
à bientôt
eh ben c'est normal
merci
et les combats pour la population n'ont
pas été portées depuis extrêmement
longtemps par par le haut par les
députés qui se sont succédé ce soit
malek boutih ou pierre allard afin de la
majorité les deux d'ailleurs dans les
majorités présidentielles mais les
boutiques dans la majorité de françois
hollande pierre allard a faim dans la
majorité de
emmanuel macron
dans l'adversité où le silence or on a
besoin de changer des choses ici
un porte à porte pour que la résignation
se transforme en vote
la présente élection prend des allures
de lutte des classes ouais un peu ouais
bah c'est bien on est tourné dans ce
moment politique
on est dans ce moment politique donc oui
un bloc populaire il faut que ce bloc
populaire deviennent majoritaires dans
ce pays pour que nos vies échanges donc
oui c'est une des classes voilà oui
c'est une lutte des classes chronique
d'une recomposition politique annoncée
c'est à 20h30 juste après cette émission
et je suis ravi d'accueillir mes trois
consoeurs et confrères bonsoir céline
crespy ou soir me remettre avec nous
c'est vous qui avez réalisé ce film
bonsoir clément père lorsque vous avez
tourné toute la partie sur le
rassemblement national qui va d'ailleurs
faire l'objet d'un magazine de 26
minutes qui sera diffusé à 13h30 samedi
prochain vous êtes en plein ventre
montage tout comme vous stéphane aider
pierre bonsoir vous vous êtes intéressé
à la droite les républicains et ses
transfuges de l air vers le parti
présidentiel pareil 26 minutes à
retrouver sur cette campagne de la
droite sur notre antenne très
prochainement céline avant de revenir
sur la séquence qu'on vient de voir qui
est très riche d'enseignements comment
est né ce projet comment vous avez tous
travailler alors d'abord c'est un projet
donc collectif et on a d'abord choisi
des circonscriptions donc des
circonscriptions entre cinq et dix au
départ du projet qui nous paraissaient
être révélateur de ce qui allait se
passer au niveau national et puis
ensuite nous avons fait notre travail de
reporter c'est à dire que nous sommes
allés sur le terrain et je dois dire que
d'abord les candidats ont accepté quand
leur met un micro hf qui donne lieu à
des séquences un peu cocasse alors voir
certaines et les électeurs c'est parce
que c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est
tout un travail à la rencontre du
terrain des français qui en dialoguant
avec le candidat raconte leurs attentes
un peu partout en france en effet on
avait à coeur aussi de montrer ses
électeurs et on a eu accès à des à des
situations de campagne qui sont comme
connus comme les marchés les boîtes âge
etc mais à d'autres situations un peu
plus inédites et donc on donner à chaque
fois ma la parole à ces français pour
voir leurs attentes et aussi ces
français qui sont un peu dégoûté de la
politique puisque je vous le rappelle un
français sur deux n'a pas voté et donc
sont souvent désabusé on s'entraîne très
rapidement que rien ne va se passer
comme prévu il ya il ya un français
d'ailleurs qui dit très clairement à ces
législatives maquereau a besoin d'un
d'un contre-pouvoir alors on va revenir
sur la séquence qu'on vient de voir
parce que là on est dans au fond
l'incarnation de la coalition de gauche
vous avez philippe riou qui est un maire
extrêmement populaire à grigny dans la
cité mère du monde comme la sellette
vous vous devez tourner cette séquence
qui va prendre un peu sous son aile le
jeune candidat insoumis rappelez-moi son
nom on soigne et oman a bouffé nos bas
effectivement on a accès à ce porte à
porte qu'un porte à porte classique et
puis on a accès à ce maire qui est très
populaire qui est reconnu comme un camp
comme un maire efficace et on va à la
rencontre de ces populations qui encore
une fois sont très très très loin des
politiques donc ils font confiance à
leur maire parce qu'ils voient
concrètement ce qui se passe mais ils
sont très très loin des génisses l'atv
sont très très loin de la présidentielle
y est donc on a un espèce de comment
voter pour nous pour que on les oublie
pas don c'est ces quartiers populaires
donc à une transmission de témoin de
certaines vrai parce que dans cet
attelage c'est très intéressant vous
avez le maire philippe riou degré me qui
est très populaire qui a un savoir-faire
qui connaît la population et vous avez
au fond le 2.0 insoumis guy un
spécialiste des réseaux sociaux qui
explique attention à s'élever n'oubliez
pas le bulletin de vote c'est ça aussi
ce que vous voulez incarné dans cette
coalition gauche oui oui c'est vrai que
c'est un attelage intéressant entre un
maire communiste et fier de l'être et en
toile né au mans qui a été celui qui a
la france a soumises a quand même
contribué à tisser toute cette toile
dont on parle beaucoup qui fait partie
de notre force de frappe 1 il faut être
tous être très honnête et donc c'est un
attelage je comprends que vous ayez
envie en tant que sur ma mise d'aller
d'aller le voir et qui a été
couronnée succès s'est révélé payant en
toile né au mans a été élu ce qui
n'était pas évident je dois le dire
parce que c'était pas une
circonscription con qu'on avait imaginé
aussi gagnable que qu'elle sait qu'elle
s'est révélée donc c'est plutôt un pari
gagnant alors on va passer au
rassemblement national avec vous clément
perreault s'est évidemment l'événement
cette élection l'arrivée en force de 89
députés rassemblement national à
l'assemblée vous avez choisi de suivre
une candidate dont l'élection en gironde
est un peu le trophée de marine le pen
deuxième extrait edwige diaz est de
toutes les fêtes de village elia sa
petite popularité non pas matérielle
impeccable donc là on voyage dans le
temps
[Musique]
il s'agit d'un choix
ben en fait parce qu'on a le même âge à
peu près
puis on est blanc de toutes les deux
mais voilà elle attend un bébé elle pas
moi
si les gens vont voter ça devrait aller
parce qu'on a quand même fait un très
très bon score
au top un peu trop sur un peu trop sur
les secondes une extrême droite oui
alors qu'on n'est pas du tout d'extrême
droite quoi
clément pourquoi il vise jazz pourquoi
l'avoir choisi elle parce que déjà je
pense qu'elle nous dit quelque chose sur
le sur le rassemblement national elle
dit quelque chose de la mutation que
cherche à opérer ce parti depuis
plusieurs depuis plusieurs années
maintenant dans ce courant elle est ce
qu'on appelle les marinistes quelqu'un
qui est venu au parti pour marine le pen
et qui est dans ce processus appelé de
normalisation là vous l'avez vu dans
cette séquence elle refuse absolument
cette étiquette d'extrême droite elles
sont très souriante très avenante elle
va beaucoup sur le terrain et il paraît
très loin avec elle le temps où le front
national était comme vivait un peu caché
là c'est quelqu'un qui va au contact qui
n'hésite pas qui veut montrer une autre
image du parti parfois c'est la séance d
une terre de conquête on va en parler
dire de conquête l'algérie a choisi
parce qu'en gironde on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir un rassemblement
national aussi fort c'est une terre avec
des votes en général assez modérée et là
c'est une circonscription qui correspond
à blaye et ses environs marine le pen
avait fait 58 % au 2e tour de la
dernière présidentielle et s'appliquer
la curiosité de beaucoup de deux
journalistes dont ceux des saints mais
vous vous l'avez vu l'efficacité de
cette campagne qu'on a dit à bas bruit
discrète loin des radars médiatiques de
marine le pen et de ses candidats et
rennes c'est vrai qu'il ya parfois eu un
décalage entre une campagne que
nationalement trouver parfois assez
discrète de marine le pen et la réalité
du terrain je pense que le rassemblement
national en réalité a fait une campagne
très ciblée ils ont une lecture je crois
très fine de la carte électorale des
élections présidentielles ils ont
identifié clairement les départements où
il était fort où ils pouvaient gagner
des circonscriptions et ils ont mis le
paquet dans ces départements là c'est là
qu'ils ont fait campagne on les a très
peu vu dans les métropoles et où il
était plus faible et c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'ils sont passés un peu en
dehors des radars mais devait passer
plusieurs jours sur le terrain avec les
candidats avec les électeurs aussi
qu'est-ce que vous avez compris de ces
électeurs là qu'ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à voter rassemblement national
ya plus de deux millions de voix
supplémentaires par rapport à 2007 pour
se partager pas vous surprendre c'est
clairement une france en colère et on
entend beaucoup parler notamment de la
problématique du pouvoir d'achat on
retrouve beaucoup d'arguments qu'on
entendait à l'époque du mouvement des
gilets jaunes c'est vraiment on se sent
l'argument le plus sensible pour eux et
marine le pen à tort ou à raison pour
beaucoup d'électeurs
et bien a été identifié comme la
candidate du pouvoir d'achat et ça ça a
été pour elle très payant électoralement
à la fois la présidence et ensuite sur
ses six têtes il vous propose de voir
rapidement une carte du rassemblement
national de toutes les circonscriptions
que le parti a gagné et ce qu'on voit
tout de suite c'est que c'est une france
plutôt rural une france où on prend
beaucoup sa voiture pour aller
travailler
qui subit de plein fouet sans doute
l'inflation également la hausse du prix
du pétrole et en bleu marine les
conquêtes législatives et on voit que la
trouve un écho beaucoup de nouveaux
territoires sur 9 8 auparavant merci
clément stéphanie à droite sur le
terrain alors heller a tout misé sur
l'ancrage local avec plus ou moins de
succès mais ce qui est intéressant dans
le film au delà des candidats qui ont
réussi cet ancrage on en parlera c'est
tous ces transfuges de l air un peu
moins que prévu mais quand même vers la
macro ni vous nous emmenez à neuilly la
ville de coeur de nicolas sarkozy aux
côtés d'une certaine constance le grip
regardez
c'est au coeur de la très chic
neuilly-sur-seine que se trame cette
histoire d'infidélité
avec une fausse commémoration en forme
de happening à la mémoire de ces députés
perdu pour le parti
et une solennité de rigueur
nous ne trahirons jamais notre famille
ne me trahiront jamais l'est républicain
pour une simple petite assiette de soupe
a dit la députée perdu pour le parti de
feu la voici constance le grip est juste
en bourse comme un feu deal c'est tout
c'est eux des biens
durables s'ils en venaient à manquer
écoutez que dites vous à ceux qui nous
ont élus je suis toujours européen je
suis toujours libéral je suis toujours
sociale je suis toujours républicaine et
je suis toujours à défendre mes
convictions sont les mêmes j'ai choisi
de répondre à l'appel au rassemblement
et au dépassement non séparée de l'état
parce que je pense que c'est vous manque
jamais de se rassembler les gagnants
stéphane yelle est incroyable cette
séquence 1 sigillée valeur nos
convictions à droite est là et la
candidate constance le grip qui va au
contact c'est pas simple mais elle va
être élu elle va être réélu et la
personne qu'on voit qui dépose cette
germes c'est la suppléante du candidat
les républicains parce que vous l'avez
compris constance le grip a été
finalement investi par la majorité
présidentielle par le camp d' emmanuel
macron alors qu'elle était députée
sortante et républicains des
républicains qui ont dégainé ensuite in
extremis à un candidat rester fidèle à
la famille et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que c'est une circonscription qui
est très symbolique puisque c'est celle
de nicolas sarkozy ça a été un fief de
l'ump des républicains constance le grip
était une proche de nicolas sarkozy et
donc elle a changé de camp ça dit
quelque chose et en fait elle a eu
raison parce que c'est la traduction du
glissement l'électorat de la droite vers
emmanuel macron constance le grip a
gagné très largement cette élection avec
74% au second tour d'eau qu'elle
explique elle a fait un changement elle
a gardé ses convictions sur le fond
c'est pas très surprenant qu'elle glisse
vers sète cette frange là
par rapport à son parcours politique
mais elle a aussi suivi ses électeurs et
donc elle a réussi regard suffisait
juste électeurs ça veut dire que les
électeurs de droite que vous avez
rencontrées sur les marchés sur le
terrain
considère qu'aujourd'hui la droite fait
macro où ils sont encore tiraillé ils
sont encore un peu tiraillé mais là à
neuilly on voit très clairement que
autant si pour les militons les députés
les républicains c'est un crève coeur ce
genre de transfuges en fait une partie
des électeurs ne voient plus beau bien
la différence parce que sur le programme
économique sur les retraites est bien
emmanuel macron
lucidité lecteur intelligent alors
peut-être aurélien pradié que vous avez
suivi aussi prouve que l'ancrage local
ça peut payer oui en fait c'était la
seule stratégie peut-être qu'il restait
aux républicains c'était de se dire on
va miser sur notre implantation sur ce
qui reste de nos députés ils ont fait
campagne sur l'ancrage local on l'a vu
aurélien pradié et là ça a marché il a
été il a été réélu si beaucoup et bien
vous savez ce qu'il vous reste à faire
vous continuez à regarder dacp c'est
donc la chronique d'une recomposition
politique c'est un film à plusieurs
mains sous la houlette de céline crespy
de l'ensemble des reporters je cite
également hélène bonduelle qui n'a pas
pu être avec nous sur ce plateau restez
avec nous sur lcp assemblée et je vais
si c'est grave c'est cécilia et
clémentine autain très belle soirée au
moins deux courtes je vous dis à demain
[Musique]